MALE SPEAKER: Shangai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
JJ BEHRENS: Hey, this
is JJ and Seth Ladd.
And this is Dartisans.
SETH LADD: And good indeed,
Dartisans not Dartisians.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I'm so
embarrassed about that.
I don't know how many times
I've misspelled it.
I'm glad we finally decided
it's Dartisans, not
Dartisians.
SETH LADD: It's all good.
Welcome, everyone.
Good morning.
Good evening, to wherever
you are.
JJ BEHRENS: Dude, it is flipping
early out here.
SETH LADD: It's OK.
I like to get started earlier.
We've got a lot of stuff to
talk about with Dart.
And a lot of stuff has happened
actually since the
last show we had, which
was really cool.
Thank to you for hosting
that, JJ.
JJ BEHRENS: It was
pretty awesome.
This is Episode 10.
We have special guests from
JetBrains to talk about their
awesome Dart plugin for
IntelliJ and WebStorm.
Have you used the editor?
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah, I started
out using it this morning.
And I'm a big IntelliJ fan.
SETH LADD: Already?
In 10 minutes, it's that good.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm excited
about this.
And these guys are from
Saint Petersburg.
So anyone in Saint Petersburg
who's watching this, like
major Brownie points for
staying up so late.
And then anyone out from
California watching this,
major Brownie points for
being up so early.
SETH LADD: Yes, awesome.
But we have a lot of
stuff to cover.
So let's go into the news real
quick, before we start
chatting with our guests.
A lot has been happening.
So we'll see what catches
JJ's ear here.
I posted how to run Dart
server apps on Heroku.
And you can find this
on my blog.
That's sethladd.com
Now this is cool, because I know
a lot of people know that
you can run Dart apps, on the
client, compiling it to
JavaScript.
But did you know that you
can run Dart just on the
standalone VM on a server?
JJ BEHRENS: Yep.
Absolutely.
And I'm psyched about this,
because since I had a
background doing Ruby on Rails,
as did you, I'm sure
both of us love Heroku.
Heroku is good stuff.
SETH LADD: And so now you can
get your Dart apps into the
cloud quite easily and start
playing around there.
So in Dart, it is possible.
Very cool.
JJ BEHRENS: One day, it'll
be App Engine.
SETH LADD: We can only hope.
JJ BEHRENS: We can only hope.
SETH LADD: So when was the
last time, JJ, that you
actually sent XML data
via XML HTTP request?
JJ BEHRENS: What's XML?
SETH LADD: Exactly.
And so the Dart team in their
continued efforts to make
programming the browser easier
have been cleaning up names.
And one of the names that
they've recently cleaned up,
or the patch is going to land
very shortly, is changing XML
HTTP requests to just
HTTP request.
How does that make you feel?
JJ BEHRENS: That really makes
me feel good inside, because
every time I saw XML HTTP
requests, it drove me nuts.
Because one of them is camel
caps and the other one isn't.
And the internal inconsistency
just makes me
feel uneasy, really.
SETH LADD: Well, I think it's
just a holdover, a legacy
component, from the
web platform.
And so it's nice to see us
cleaning up these names.
The other cool fact about this
is that it's one of the most
highly starred feature
requests--
JJ BEHRENS: Is that right?
SETH LADD: --in our HTML
component in the bug tracker.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm glad we
got the important
things settled first.
SETH LADD: No, this is good.
I love handling the top feature
requests from the community.
And so keep voting and keep
starring for issues.
It really does make
a difference.
JJ BEHRENS: Absolutely.
SETH LADD: Kevin Moore, a Dart
contributor-- he's actually in
the author's file and also has
published some really cool
open source libraries--
has begun working on a
Minesweeper clone in Dart,
which is very cool,
because he is
publishing a developer diary.
JJ BEHRENS: I heard that it's
going to be more fun, because
it's HTML5.
I mean, that's going to just
make it more playable.
SETH LADD: Well, 16% more
playable, at least.
We can measure these things.
And so, see, you can follow
along with how
he's doing, his progress.
It's all open source, and he
blogs about what works and
what didn't.
It's very educational.
Speaking about games, Danny
Hendrix has released a
significant update
to his 2D game.
And I don't know too many
details about this.
But he posted a screenshot,
and it's really cool.
It gives me the warm
fuzzy about the old
8-bit console games.
JJ BEHRENS: I was thinking about
the fact that I have a
64-bit machine, but all
of the fun bits are in
the lowest 8 bits.
SETH LADD: That's good.
Well, he's going to keep
working on that.
And you can follow along
with that on Google+.
Now, this is really cool.
So Dockspawn--
S-P-A-W-N spawn--
is a web-based dock layout
engine that aids in creating
flexible user interfaces by
enabling panels to be docked
on the screen similar to
Visual Studio IDE.
Now that's their description.
But I checked this out.
And this is really cool.
Because it looks like
a really appy app.
And the kicker is Dockspawn
is built with Dart.
JJ BEHRENS: That sounds
really awesome.
But I got nothing funny
to say about it.
SETH LADD: I like to see people
use Dart to really
build those kind of apps that
you would have seen maybe on
native mobile or desktop and
really bring the app
back into Web App.
So I'm very excited to
see what Dockspawn is
going to put out.
We've seen Dart be really
interesting to a lot of Java
developers.
And Daniel Zwicker--
I hope I said that right--
released his Java Maven
plug-in for Dart.
This is awesome.
So now you can integrate Dart to
JS into your Maven workflow
and integrate, as a
first class, Dart
into your Java projects.
JJ BEHRENS: So for all those
people out there wondering
whether they should use Ant or
Maven, the answer is Maven.
SETH LADD: It's Maven now,
if you want to be a good
Dartisian-- uh, I almost
said Dartisian.
JJ BEHRENS: Dartisans.
SETH LADD: See?
Dartisans, that's right.
Moving back over to the Dart
project, Gilad Bracha, our
language spec author and guest
and friend of the show, has
published Dart's modest
proposal for Mixins.
JJ BEHRENS: I love
me some Mixins.
SETH LADD: It's good.
You can find this on
news@dartlang.org.
And my impression is that it's
not meant to be the last thing
we see about Mixins.
But it is meant to sort of get
Dart's feet wet with Mixins,
and something that's a little
bit more tangible, and
something we can start talking
about a little more concrete
for the post M1 world.
Now, have you read
this spec at all?
JJ BEHRENS: I haven't read it.
I was planning on reading
it later today.
But I was thinking about the
fact that you have C++ with
multiple inheritance, and you
have Ruby with Mixins and
Small Talk with Mixins.
And then you have traits from
the Scala background.
These are all overlapping
things.
And so I think we're going have
to get Gilad on the show
and talk about why Mixins
why not Traits?
What is the small difference
between those two different
features that caused us to
pick the term Mixins?
And maybe it's because of our
Small Talk background.
SETH LADD: Yeah.
The Dart editor team,
now, this is great.
This is a highly, highly
requested feature.
It has released their Dart
plug-in for Eclipse.
JJ BEHRENS: That's awesome.
SETH LADD: So you might
be aware that--
JJ BEHRENS: Not really.
We have the IntelliJ
guys right there.
SETH LADD: That's great.
We're going to talk to them
in just a minute.
We publish the Dart Editor.
And this is a standalone editing
experience, everything
you need out of the box.
But a lot of people like
their Eclipse.
They like their plug-ins.
They like being able to plug-in
the Git workflow and
save their HTML5 syntax
highlighter, whatever it is.
They've been asking, how do I
get Dart over into that world?
And you can try that out now.
And you get auto update, the
regular old plug-in install.
JJ BEHRENS: I'm happy to tell
people that it now works.
Because I've been asked
this many times.
SETH LADD: And so this
is very cool.
Have you heard about
Web Components?
JJ BEHRENS: I have heard
about Web Components.
SETH LADD: What do
they mean to you?
JJ BEHRENS: I think that Web
Components are finally
building something at the
browser level that everyone's
been doing at a framework level
for a really long time.
And because of that, I think
we're going to see better
integration between multiple
frameworks.
SETH LADD: Indeed, in fact,
as a developer in other
platforms, when I came to the
web, the first thing that
struck me was I couldn't
subclass button.
I found that totally bizarre.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
unacceptable.
SETH LADD: So Web Components
will allow
me to subclass button.
And there's a whole bunch
of other aspects to Web
Components out there.
JJ BEHRENS: Is that the whole
reason GWT got started, just
to subclass buttons?
SETH LADD: I don't know.
JJ BEHRENS: I suspect so.
SETH LADD: So we highly
encourage you, if you are a
cutting edge web developer and
want to know what's coming
down for the future of web
development, check out Web
Components.
And they really do have the
potential to improve
client-side web engineering.
On that note, you can see one
of the ways Dart might play
well with Web Components in the
future by our GitHub Repo
Dart Web Components.
And you can see some examples
there and some early R&D about
how you can actually build
and consume Web
Components in Dart.
JJ BEHRENS: That's
exciting stuff.
SETH LADD: The last bit of news
I have here is-- speaking
of GitHub--
the www site for dartlang.org
is now posted to GitHub.
And we've had some requests to
help with fixing typos or bugs
or contributing articles
to the main site.
We love it.
We hope it happens.
Since now we're on GitHub,
so you can contribute.
It's just a pull request away.
You can find the www site plus
a whole bunch of other great
Dart sub projects as
well on GitHub.
So I highly encourage everyone
to get involved.
And we'll see you on GitHub.
JJ BEHRENS: Yeah.
A lot of companies ask you for
your GitHub account these days
to see your contributions
to open source.
And I've always found that one
of the best ways to get
started contributing to an
open-source project is finding
grammar typos in the
documentation and submitting
pull requests.
And so now I'm excited,
because I won't be
the one doing it.
You guys out there
will be doing it.
SETH LADD: You can approve
their pull requests.
That's exactly the low-hanging
fruit we
want to try to encourage.
And so help out, and we'll
be there to help
you along the way.
Well, that's the news
that I had today.
JJ BEHRENS: That was
a lot of news.
But now we get to go talk
to the JetBrains guys.
SETH LADD: This is awesome.
So let's flip over to Hangout
and welcome our special
guests, all the way from
Russia, from JetBrains.
Hello guys, welcome.
KIRILL: Hello.
FEDOR: Hello.
JJ BEHRENS: So you guys want
to introduce yourselves.
KIRILL: Yep.
Let me start.
My name is Kirill.
I work for JetBrains
in IntelliJ IDEA
and WebStorm teams.
My focus is to coordinate the
activity that goes for
[INAUDIBLE] development,
JavaScripts, and all around.
And I also contribute to Flash
and Flex parts of IntelliJ and
in the core of [INAUDIBLE].
FEDOR: And my name is Fedor.
I work at JetBrains, too.
And I'm developing the
Dart plug-in for
IntelliJ and WebStorm.
Also, I'm developing a Hex
plug-in for IntelliJ and some
other plug-ins.
JJ BEHRENS: So you guys want
to show us what you've got?
SETH LADD: First off,
thank you for
building a Dart plug-in.
This is so awesome.
And I know that almost right
when the project launched,
everyone's like, well, when is
IntelliJ going to get here?
And so it's really, really cool
that you guys are helping
out the community and building
such a great
product with Dart support.
So thank you for that.
And I think you're right.
I think if you guys can do a
demo for everyone, that would
be fantastic.
Show us what we can do.
KIRILL: Let me probably
spend some minutes
on introducing IntelliJ.
Or if you think everyone
knows what is that?
SETH LADD: I think most
people know, but
go ahead and explain.
I mean, we hear words like
PhpStorm and WebStorm and
IntelliJ and JetBrains.
So certainly, yeah, try to put
this in context for us.
JJ BEHRENS: Maybe they want to
be modest, so let me brag for
you guys a little bit.
I went to Pi-Con a couple years
ago, and we had an IDEs
panel, where we had all the
different Python IDEs.
And the JetBrains guys were
there to represent PyCharm.
And so you had the PyDev guys,
and you had PyCharm, and you
had Wing IDE, and the EMACs
guys, and so forth.
And all the guys were showing
the coolest features.
And PyCharm just cleaned up.
I mean, it was just
ridiculous.
It was like, yeah, we have
all those features.
And all these features
you haven't even
thought about yet.
It was kind of ridiculous.
SETH LADD: Now, I'm excited.
I want to see how this works.
KIRILL: And the question I get,
from time to time, is how
does IntelliJ correspond to the
WebStorm and PyCharm and
all the products on
the team platform?
So basically, IntelliJ is like
a super set of all the
functionality that we have.
It's like a platform with
more than 100 plug-ins.
And for instance, WebStorm,
which is focused on web
development, it's
like 35 plug-ins
are bundled by default.
The same for PyCharm and for
RubyMine, which is for web
developers.
And so WebStorm is focused on
that, on JavaScript, on CSS,
on Node and CoffeeScript,
on stuff like this.
And our plug-in is available for
IntelliJ and for WebStorm
and other products as well.
So no matter what you have, what
products have you got,
you will get all of those
functionality with you.
JJ BEHRENS: But you guys don't
support COBOL though, right?
KIRILL: I have to check
with the plug-in repo.
Maybe there is plug-in
for a COBOL.
I'm not sure.
SETH LADD: Don't underestimate
it.
JJ BEHRENS: You know, one day.
KIRILL: There is a 300
plug-ins on our
repo, so I'm not sure.
I will check, meanwhile.
SETH LADD: Well, as Fedor and
Kirill are getting ready to do
their demo with the screenshare,
I want to remind
everyone watching that
you can go to
developers@google.com/live and
ask and vote for questions.
At the end of the demo and after
our chat, we will go
ahead and go through the
Moderator questions.
So if you want to talk
to these guys, go
ahead and go there.
But guys, why don't you share
your screen and walk us
through some of the features.
FEDOR: So let's share it.
So I know that manuals for Dart
users who want so much.
And we have a real nice format
for implementation.
So it's a format of settings.
You have a bunch of different
properties with spaces,
idents, and so on.
So, for example, let's change
some spaces, and add a comma,
and add the space
before comma.
So at the right side, you can
see what is changing.
So I don't know if you
guys see it or not.
JJ BEHRENS: That's a nice
feature, because we don't have
a tool for that.
FEDOR: Of course, you can
change wrappings.
For example, let's wrap
a whole statement.
Oops.
Sorry.
So I took my favorite example
from the SDK.
It's a clock example.
And add [INAUDIBLE].
So currently, the clock
shows server uptime.
So before start, let's refactor
a little bit.
So the clock get message from
the sever every second.
So let's introduce
our message.
And you see that in IntelliJ
can find duplicates.
So let's replace all the
duplicates, and it's a message.
Let's [INAUDIBLE].
So here is the message.
The message is just a date
in a string format.
So you can debug both
server-side and client-side
applications in IntelliJ.
I think we're done with
launching the application.
Now I'm going to show
so some other
cool features of IntelliJ.
So it really matters that you
have a good tool when you are
learning a new language
or discovering
someone else's code.
So, for example, let's
find out how to
change number of colors.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
FEDOR: And let's check
that file structure.
So I see that we have out
of date time method.
So here is it.
And we can see that clock number
represented by clock
number plus.
So clock number plus has
that bold color field.
Let's find usage of
the bold color.
Here is a nice view.
So it turns out that
bold color is an
index in array of images.
Nice.
Let's go to a bold class.
So of course you can explore
the structure of the class.
And you see the tons of
different properties.
And for example, you can easily
see the implementation
of random velocities.
It shows random velocity, and
you can go through each item
and the code is updating.
So I think that was a
[INAUDIBLE] method, so I
filter by [INAUDIBLE].
Here we're changing some
stuff and so on.
So, of course, we
can check with
implementation on the fly.
But here is it.
Let's introduce the variable,
the place and date.
Now, for example, I don't
want [INAUDIBLE].
And I remain [INAUDIBLE]
for example in the
[INAUDIBLE].
So with latest version of Dart
plugin, which will be
available in a few hours, we
have unit testing support.
So here we have unit test.
So just one of them.
Here is it, nice
three of tests.
You can observe a step
[INAUDIBLE].
Also you can run a test
from the context.
For example, I want to create a
one consideration for a bad
test group.
So I just right-click on
that all and run it.
SETH LADD: Now, is that using
the unit test library that
ships with the SDK?
FEDOR: Yes.
SETH LADD: That's fantastic.
FEDOR: I have to develop
something in Dart.
So I don't know what
to show you.
I think I forgot something.
KIRILL: Maybe you can show
us on generating stuff
FEDOR: Oh, of course.
Generating--
KIRILL: Or like live template
suites or--
FEDOR: Oh, right, right,
I'm sorry, of course.
Let's go to the server.
We have a stopwatch tick.
It sends a date message
to the client.
So let's introduce
our message.
Then, for example, I don't
like ForEach method, then
remove it, and iterate.
And IntelliJ suggests to you
the components which has
iterable type.
So in my case it's
connections.
So we can--
it's connection.
And, of course, you
get completion.
And now the sample
about generation.
I don't know what to generate.
Let's generate some example
I don't have a file.
KIRILL: Can you maybe also show
th3 color schemes and how
you can highlight the source
codes with many colors?
JJ BEHRENS: We don't care
about things like type
completion and refactoring.
We really just want to
see color schemes.
KIRILL: When you are going to
use your tool all day, like 10
hours a day, it can be very
important that you have the
right colors, and your eyes
are relaxed, and so on.
FEDOR: In IntelliJ, you can
choose color for sometimes the
[INAUDIBLE]
items, for example, for class
names and interfaces.
So, for example, I want all of
these really, really pink.
KIRILL: So you can spend a lot
of time setting up this stuff.
FEDOR: And the interface
green.
Whoops!
Yeah, I want the interface
and I think it's--
yes, it's true-- interface.
Maybe another cool feature
is landmark.
For example, let's go
to the list class.
So let's check the old classes
that [INAUDIBLE].
For example, in that
IntelliJ, you have
landmarkers on there up.
And we have both sides
and up and down.
My demo.
SETH LADD: Great.
Thank you.
JJ BEHRENS: I think we
have 10 minutes left.
And we got a bunch of
questions lined up.
SETH LADD: We do have
some questions.
My first question is how much or
if any of the Dart SDK are
you guys using to build
the plug-in?
FEDOR: We don't use Dart as the
key like Synergy does all
the syntax parsing of the AXT
building and on all the
completion of the result
on itself.
So we just integrated Dart
as the key to execute the
launcher, the debugger,
and test runner.
SETH LADD: So you have your own
static analyzer feature?
FEDOR: Yeah.
JJ BEHRENS: And there's a lot
of things to implement.
And how far have
you come along?
And how far do you have left
to go, before you are very
comfortable with the plug-in?
Are there big things that you
think are missing still?
FEDOR: I think we need a bunch
of feedback, because, of
course, I'm using it.
But I think, for example, 100
people would be using it, then
we will get proper feedback,
then we'll
be absolutely great.
Because I think now there is
some bugs, of course, and we
need to fix them.
SETH LADD: We'll get
you feedback.
KIRILL: In general, we brought
all the basic stuff, like we
can understand the language.
We can parse the language.
And all the foundation
is there.
And right now there is a lot of
refactoring features that
we can implement this or that.
And so to choose which way to
go, we probably need some more
feedback from you guys,
from users.
Actually, right now, there is
only Fedor working on the
plug-in, a single person
working on the plug-in.
And no one in the company,
except him, uses Dart plug-in
internally.
Because we have like, I don't
know, several dozens of
technologies to work on.
Each one, each guy works
on his own [INAUDIBLE]
list.
And it's really impossible to
try like all the technologies
that we have.
JJ BEHRENS: I see that
you guys already
have had 4,000 downloads.
And so I think it's just a
matter of time before you get
lots of feedback.
KIRILL: Oh yeah, we get more and
more feedback every day.
And expect for even more,
because only you real users
can help us to choose the
direction to move and to find
the most critical bugs.
SETH LADD: Well, we have some
questions from the Moderator.
So let's go to those.
So Kai from Finland wants to
know, "Is there a plan to have
the almighty Inspection
Power Pack for Dart?"
FEDOR: Ah, yes.
We used Dart Analyzer and in the
next version that will be
available in few hours, there
is a huge improvement in
working with Analyzer.
So it works really well.
SETH LADD: Neo writes, "Is the
Mirrors API going to work on
the client side, and when should
we expect to see it?"
So this isn't an IntelliJ
specific question.
The answer is, yes, the Mirrors
API will work on the
client side.
When should we expect
to see it?
I'm not sure.
But I know that a lot of work is
happening on it right now.
It's pretty important.
JJ BEHRENS: It's important.
It's coming.
Here's one for JetBrains.
How is the Pub Package Manager
support going for the Dart
plug-in in IntelliJ?
FEDOR: Yes, the latest version
of the plug-in
supports the Pub.
JJ BEHRENS: That's impressive.
SETH LADD: What does
that mean exactly?
What can you do?
FEDOR: So we can install
packages and date packages.
Also IntelliJ adds the new
package flag to the
[INAUDIBLE]
options.
And, of course, we resolve
the package through this.
JJ BEHRENS: Great.
SETH LADD: Yeah, thank you
for working on that.
I know that Pub is going to
really enable all of our third
party developers to build
their own libraries and
release them and publish them.
It's really cool.
Let's see, what's the status
of the proposal decision to
remove explicit interfaces
from the spec.
W. Brian from Madison.
JJ BEHRENS: I don't know.
I'm sorry.
SETH LADD: It's going
to happen.
I think the new version
spec should get
published pretty soon.
And that will essentially
become the M1 spec.
And that will have explicit
interfaces moving.
And then each class has their
own implicit interface that
they project into the world.
JJ BEHRENS: More
like Go there.
SETH LADD: I think
it opposite.
So in the Dart world
a class has its
own implicit interface.
JJ BEHRENS: Yes.
SETH LADD: And you can
implement a class.
But in Go, I think it's
the other way around.
If you happen to conform
this thing, then
you are this thing.
JJ BEHRENS: Boy, and Seth
just schooled me.
SETH LADD: That's because I
got schooled on this exact
thing earlier.
So Robert asks, when will get a
new version of the plug-in.
It's been four weeks since
your last update.
JJ BEHRENS: Four weeks?
SETH LADD: A couple hours,
is that right?
FEDOR: Yes.
SETH LADD: We should actually
ask them this point.
How does one get the Dart
plug-in for IntelliJ?
How does one get started?
Do I have to buy IntelliJ?
Do I have to get WebStorm?
How do you recommend
someone start?
KIRILL: You can download
a version of
IntelliJ at our web store.
It is free for one month.
So you have 30 days to try
it and then decide
to buy it or not.
And you start it.
You can actually check out
the video from Fedor.
It's how to install
the plug-in.
So you basically open
[INAUDIBLE]
to go to plug-in repo
and then choose
the plug-in and install.
Restart the IDE,
and that's it.
Then you create the new
file and you're done.
Or you can just clone the
project from GitHub.
You go to main menu and
check that GitHub.
And then enter your credentials,
choose the repo,
and you're done.
JJ BEHRENS: It took me three
minutes this morning, doing it
for the first time.
SETH LADD: And I should probably
not that you guys
have sales every once
in a while too.
And I'm just going
to get up on my
soapbox for just a minute.
Every once in a while I'll hear
like, ah, but IntelliJ
costs money.
But the way I look at is like
the master craftsman really
invests in his tools, and he
really takes pride in the
tools he curates, and
collects, and
takes care of them.
And those things are with
him for a long time.
And I think master web engineers
should think of
their tools in the same way.
Investing in their tools is
a completely reasonable
investment in their
own career.
And so take a look at IntelliJ
as an option.
JJ BEHRENS: And I would even
say that a master tools-man
knows how to use
multiple tools.
So sometimes he might need a
wrench, and sometimes he might
need a socket set.
And so, in the same way, I
have both Dart Editor and
IntelliJ and WebStorm, all
working at the same time.
I could do both VI and EMACs
because you wouldn't
code LISP in VI.
And there's lots of things
where I would prefer
to code it in VI.
SETH LADD: Well, here's
a great one for
the JetBrains guys.
Latislav, who is a really active
and helpful guy in the
mailing list, wants to know,
"What parts of Dart are the
most challenging to support in
an IDE such as IntelliJ?"
FEDOR: I think the library.
Because the common.library
contains only inputs and
source statements.
And when you, for example,
include the tool.files, for
example, a.dart and b.dart,
you have to complete
references from in a.dart
from b.dart.
I don't know.
Do you understand me?
SETH LADD: This is
great feedback.
FEDOR: That's the
difficult part.
JJ BEHRENS: You have to
really, really, really
understand the import
semantics.
SETH LADD: And I think it's
bitten a couple people on the
mailing list a couple times.
So this is a tip for
everyone watching.
If you import the same file via
two different URIs, Dart
will treat that as two
separate namespaces.
You can have a collision, even
though it's the same class.
So be aware of that.
And try to import from
the same URI.
Well, we're running
out of time.
So I'm sorry we didn't get
to all of the questions.
JJ BEHRENS: Sorry about that.
SETH LADD: But I do want to
say, thanks to our guests.
Spasibo, for staying up
late and joining us.
KIRILL: Thank you.
FEDOR: Thank you guys.
SETH LADD: For everyone watching
the live stream or
catching us late, everything is
recorded, posted to YouTube.
And you can subscribe to
Dartisans via our podcast,
which is also in iTunes.
So lots of easy ways
to get them.
So we'll post this up
in a little bit.
And you could watch it later.
You can catch all the episodes,
this and all the
previous episodes, at
dartlang.org/dartisans.
And we've got the videos on
there and links to the
podcast, so lots of
different ways.
And just thanks everyone
for watching.
Dart is still technology
preview.
But we are aiming really,
really fast
towards the M1 release.
And so these kind of feedbacks,
these kind of chats
are really, really helpful.
So stay involved in
the mailing list,
dartlang.org/mailing-list.
Stack Overflow is full of
awesome Dart community members
helping out with the tag Dart.
Lots of ways to get involved.
Things around GitHub.
And thanks for following
along.
It's getting really exciting.
So we'll see you next
time on Dartisans.
Thank you JetBrains.
KIRILL: Thank you.
SETH LADD: Bye-bye.